thanks Wayne jumping Studios in the
heart of Los Angeles this is screen
junkies movie finds now your host Andy
signor brought to you by t-mobile now
Netflix has included another reason why
t-mobile is America's best unlimited
network hello screen junkies welcome to
another live episode of movie fights I'm
so happy I did it I loved it because
every time you're back the fans like
finally watch the video will never watch
it I've never watched it now in his
movies hated but we have some fun stuff
today we're gonna be pitching face for
Marvel movies we're also gonna be
talking about what movie was a bigger
improvement over its source material and
which movie will be improved by making
it the LEGO version instead so stay
tuned you can watch along on Twitter and
the YouTube comments section hashtag
movie fights live chime in will be doing
votes and some other fun stuff
throughout the show so stay tuned lawn
Harris will be over there in the in
thread states and stands on vacation of
FSU which I think it's tonight his thing
yes I hope I didn't marry miss her it's
happening right now but go support Dan
and leash over there watching Wonder
Woman and a nice log of doing so have
thanks Dan and have fun happy for him
their lon happy to have you here they'll
fact-checking today delighted to be here
yeah I can't wait to keep arguing about
mother for two hours mother warm up
discussion which we'll do later and next
year so happy to have Nico welcome Nico
a new man the fake him excited you're
here for a max landis special are you
excited or worried
I'm excited cuz give go long time and
next to him and thank you for cutting in
man look what Ian made us this amazing
fan art which looks so he put a momma
vegan shirt which now everyone hates me
because I've gone sort of
cherien I'm trying to do more vegan but
I can't give the most vegan thing I've
ever seen is raising a sign with a
picture there's my I made my vegan line
of the day I thank you for coming
now you excited you alright good I might
come to you throughout the show for some
help so pay attention it's about the
arguments here so we'll be fighting it's
he's back I'm so happy to have
screenwriter director showrunner max
Landis welcome back sir I'm happy to be
here are you doing you got some you got
some rest from Dirk to and now you're
are you just still not no rest for the
weary hi I came right off Dirk and went
right into all my other stuff yes don't
movin yeah it's um it's a lot yeah but I
came I'm here yes thankfully you did my
fellow fighters yeah yeah I know you you
love you respect the show that's what I
love about you you take this seriously
yeah and we brought two serious fighters
to take you on I'm so happy to have her
the energy fear of screen junkies news
and host of SJ you were reporting we're
off Cornett Ross are you ready
I don't know I'm already and you are you
bring the fire don't don't be cooler I
don't to give up your secrets there but
I know you're gonna yield tussle here
with max I'm excited to have you next to
you it's this movie fights champion
tussle I don't even know if max knows
this but Dan Merle lost the Bell Ashton
the money enhance dancer earns about he
is now the champion and you actually
lost to max and his first one fight I'm
that's true that's true and that's why I
want to take the belt and not put it on
my movie
force we will force him at some point
but he's here to fight and his call he
don't know then I know that we're gonna
stretch that out a little bit longer
this will be a good fight and obviously
you guys know how this is played I'm
listening to facts creativity passion
but let's just get to this shall we
alright guys question 1 in honor of
kinsman's I go ahead Thank You max that
max tomb it's always I have I've emailed
the wrong max so many times I mean honor
of Kingsman the Golden Circle what
country should get its own Kingsman in a
third film and who should play the
group's leader so obviously if you
haven't seen the Kingsmen the Golden
Circle which opens tonight I believe in
most theaters they introduced the
statesman led by Jeff Bridges Channing
Tatum what other country should get its
own Kingsman and who should play it max
you're leading us off hey being first um
short answer what I loved about the
original Kingsman is it showed us Colin
Firth in a context that we had never
seen him as the action hero as James
Bond sort of Colin Firth is from a
generation of actors which has a bunch
of lost James Bond's you know guys who
could have been that guy and weren't and
ended up dating Bridget Jones and I
really feel like a guy who you could
pick up and do something really amazing
with because he's a great actor he's a
great stuntman he's a great director
he's an incredible creator is Jackie
Chan Jackie has his own version of taken
coming out pretty soon I'm not sure what
it's called but I'm gonna [ __ ] and see
it looks because I miss him Jackie Chan
is a figure who brings warmth and heart
to whatever he does in the universe is
cynical and vicious as the Kingsmen
universe which survives by attacking and
destroying tropes of the spy genre I
want to see them do that
both kung fu' can you imagine a Matthew
Vaughn directed kung-fu fight with
Jackie [ __ ] Chan I mean like that's
the sort of [ __ ] that on its own as a
three-minute scene gets five million
views on YouTube and I want to see an
entire Chinese cast and what I really
want and I really want this is to do
Kingsman the branding of it's this
genre but then a little bit twisted with
60s and 70s kung fu spy movies because
there are a lot of those and I want to
go down to like having dubbing jokes
like I don't want to do full like kung
fu hustle like whatever the [ __ ] it was
enter the chicken or whatever the [ __ ]
that movie and also China has its entire
own film industry with its own movie
stars how cool would it be to get some
actual Chinese movie stars in this movie
everybody talks about KO phi they're
forcing China into blockbuster movies
yeah you just did it spearheaded by
Jackie Chan I didn't have to force it
it's welcome I'm inviting its left the
right one in that little vampire girl is
Jackie Chan and I want him to come in
and seduce me seduce me by doing a
backflip at age 60 whatever he wants to
see that taken but he'll be better in my
Kingsman here's your take I like the
Jackie Chan vampire movie you just pitch
right there at the end
I mean came with the Kingsmen though the
truth is that it's always gonna maintain
the through-line of these central
characters that they established in the
first film and you'll see that even in
Kingsman 2 so it's really about
expanding the world in a way that
creates something fun and new and
innovative for it so I'm pitching to go
to a place in a fight style that we
haven't seen a ton actually in film at
all we're just to go to Brazil and do
couple where and that is a fight style
that is incredibly cool it is like a
dance it is physical it is beautiful we
have not seen this a ton on film at all
and I'm pitching Gisele Bundchen as the
head of that and the joke is
she's actually 65 years old and the
thing about this Brazilian Kingsman is
that they are incredibly physical that
they use their beauty as a tool as well
and the plot of the film essentially is
that we've dealt now with global warming
in the first one there's another element
in this one that I won't get into too
much but this one is about technology
and it's about releasing the EMP that
under this technology and they have to
go to people that can use their
physicality and that's why they go to
this group of people they are physical
they are fighters they can use their
allure to fight they're all ridiculously
beautiful
and yeah i would go with rodrigo santoro
is well in that group from west world
there you go come in Brazil Brazil China
Spencer were you taking us
oh man so we've got the Kingsmen right
yeah and we've got where the Americans
statesman statesman let's go up north
and get the moose men going out east
amwell them they have the Mounties these
are the top-secret Mounties men they
actually ride mooses and I think the
Meese Minh yeah excuse me what my
favorite part of the Kingsmen movie I
thought the first one was lowland even
cuz I loved the first part so much more
than the second part I loved the
training of this like my fair lady of
eggsy the kid from the streets who's
getting trained to become like super
smooth and Secret Service II so let's
get Jane Tatum and eggsy who are now
like refined cool they've got all
together to have to start a new Kingsman
franchisor Moosman up north and kind of
have their dumb little brother canadians
have to learn to be secret agents it's
like the development of learning to
enter this world that was the fun part
of that movie and then they're gonna
learn that like you know what not
everybody has to be like manners maketh
man and all smooth we can let the
Canadians be the Canadians and have them
wear the denim suits and have the
razor-sharp hockey sticks and have the
burning hot maple syrup and all that
cool stuff and they're gonna be led by
none other than Canadian actor Mike
Meyers who we've always wanted him to be
in like an r-rated not an r-rated but
like a gritty Austin Powers reboot but
that's not gonna happen so let's get
Mike Meyers in an r-rated spy action
movie franchise all right fight it out
you should do I start whoever would go
okay I'm gonna straight up say Mike
Meyers is not a good or self-aware
enough actor to be in one of these
movies he's best in roles that are
incredibly broad I think she's L
bündchen actually is a is a tighter
choice but you know he's the best choice
of those three who could actually keep
up with the pace of a Kingsman movie is
Jackie Chan I also want to say before
and then you can continue the
iconography of Brazil
soccer and capoeira the iconography of
Canada mostly a joke mostly things that
Canadians themselves I just spent six
months there talk about as a joke the
politeness they make fun of themselves
about it all the time it's already funny
but when you look at the stuff in the
Kingsmen movies the Statesmen [ __ ] we
skee lassos six-shooters it's cool the
[ __ ] from England the suits the British
suits the umbrellas all that [ __ ] it's
cool so you're going with like the
surface levels starett of like oh
they're Asian and Chinese so they all do
come fine and say they're Asian and
Chinese
I says who do come food that's an actual
cool thing they do the Americans are
Cowboys the British are extremely
primitive
this is a cultural thing you can make
jokes about maple syrup or you can take
things that are actually cool about a
culture a hyper collectivist intensely
determined incredibly physically
powerful group of this is the
iconography of China is incredible the
swords the Dragons all of this [ __ ]
could be given second life it's a
technology it's like Oh Chinese kung fu
masters with Dragons and there are a few
things
don't be your vaccines max there are a
few things I want to see before I die
and one of them is not a brokedown
Jackie Chan trying to do kung fu on
screen that would so kill me because
he's fat check how old Jackie Chan is
now he doesn't have it anymore that's
why he's not doing come for movies and a
Jackie Chan taken to me just sounds sad
to just see him barely thrown out chops
you should just like really the trailer
looks [ __ ] dope they must like CGI
Tarkan him or do like that Liam Neeson
thing there's 13 cuts to get him over a
Ledge I don't want to see Mike Myers in
a movie but yeah I see model turned
actress we're going there first she's
never been to move first of all your
kitchen was already done literally done
and over done in Austin Powers so why do
we really need to see that
well he's not playing a British guys
playing Canadian guy it doesn't matter
he's still playing that same kind of
character and it's it he's making a
mockery of a mock it's putting a holster
that needs to learn to be a secret it
just essentially adds nothing to a
franchise that's built on being fresh
and adding new things if you go the
movie that you pitch sounds really fun
but on its own as a completely separate
version of the Kingsmen if you're
actually going to integrate and expand
out you don't want something that's
gonna steal the show entirely from the
established characters because what the
film
does in the sequel is continued to build
on those characters so you really just
want something that's gonna add an
element to that world you're able to
introduce a country that we don't see
all the time on film it's gonna be
innovative exciting fighting because we
haven't seen it too many times before
and it is not Zoolander oh they're
breakdance fighting oh no not at all if
you guys go look up Caballero right now
I'm telling you you are gonna love it
and you're gonna want to see that in a
film especially a film directed by
Matthew Vaughn who's going to be able to
execute on that and there's an inherent
plot device that works in that you can
get sucker into this movie you get epic
beautiful landscapes in this movie from
Brazil you get the iconography of Brazil
in this movie and your soccer and soccer
is a huge point Nima's could be in this
movie he was in freakin xxx he can be in
Kingsman it's never yep that's always
gonna do this exactly an hour ago there
you go having said that I still truly
believe that this would be the best
addition to this franchise and there's a
million different ways that you can play
with it especially they have all their
gadgets right what if that was wiped
away from them and they needed to just
get physical and this is the group that
could teach them to do it and suddenly
you've got Colin Firth and all of them
needing to a not only learn to be more
physical which he is already in this
film but get their sexy on that's a fun
twist to this these just all sound too
serious and what I like about Kingsman
is it's got a light tone and it was half
comedy because Rowell has the head of an
open area scusa
I will say I just say the thing about
these three arguments is that they're
coming it came in a different way you're
addressing Kingsman as though it's
primarily a comedy you're addressing
Kingsman as though you're really making
the third Kingsman movie i am coming at
it from a place of this will be funny
it's a Kingsman movie I just want to do
the coolest thing possible
like it's three different schools of
thought on it none of us
I feel like this the first movie fight
I've been in where none of our arguments
are actually better than the other ones
arguments your final thoughts tonight
will be coming to you guys to help me
here because this is the three versions
I'd watch Spencer final thoughts yeah
you transformers Kingsman you're going
to China you put Jackie Chan in it and
trying to sell it globally and I get
that that's a cynical classic move I am
embracing I'm embracing this movie as I
think it works is the dynamic between
America and Britain who's right in
between America's hat Canada and we all
want to see Mike Meyers in an r-rated
role and you can look at one didn't want
to save this impulse as my trump card
you bring in every other hot Canadian
actor you bring in Reynolds you bring in
Gosling you bring in Jim Carrey as like
the Canadian Expendables oh my god I'm
seeing this on day one yeah I accept
that that becomes an overloaded debt to
dance movie that actually doesn't work
if you stay focusing you don't have
people that are gonna pull focus from
the characters that you care about but
are actually just gonna elevate it and
expand this world and do something we
haven't seen two million times on screen
and make references that we haven't seen
too many times on screen that's a movie
I want to see it's still a Kingsman
movie it's an exciting thing to me movie
plus you get a Tom Brady cameo a lot of
that so you called me you called me
cynical but then you don't want to have
cameo land what do you do Zoolander - I
I respect the idea of Brazil but for me
ultimately Kingsman isn't about doing
things we haven't seen before there's
nothing in kings when we haven't seen
before it's our man Flint its James Bond
but it's done funny better and cooler
well I think a genre that deserves that
treatment free of franchising and I'm
sorry about my blue Tom but free of
franchising is kung-fu and I feel like
using Jackie Chan in that way where he's
the head of the organization
he only has one actions apiece but it's
incredible and then you use really good
kung-fu Chinese actors not just I would
be so excited if there was a movie
called like Kingsman red dragon or
something like it that sounds cool I've
fair enough I'd be excited to see all
three of these movies but I would be
different levels of excited and it'd be
the most for mine alright someone
getting a red lollipop to you let's go
to catch your LAN what do you think well
I mean I do I think all these pitches
were pretty good and I was I was sort of
with Spencer until the end and then I
don't really love Canadian Expendables
trump card but almost was the answer the
facts though 63 years old that's how old
Jackie Chan is been through a lot that's
great yeah he looks great his melodies a
made of sandpaper that I also find he
was way older like that's I probably
would've guessed 70 and then Spencer did
offend some Canadians with his original
pitch but then they did apologize for
being a fan all right guys what do you
think I thought Spencer had the best
like blowbacks so that put him in the
lead flow makes it like argument wise I
want to see a Jackie Jen I can see the
come up the comedy when they first meet
him like this is the guy he's old and
then he just whoops faster ass and you
agree or dude yeah okay you're not miked
so you have talking to Mike next time
but I hopefully they read you but yes
they both agreed with max this was tough
legitimate because I actually do agree
there's something interesting here but
whether it was two shining it what he
said like transformers in it and going
to straight China I don't know if that
matter you did give me actually
interesting take and I like to it could
spin off into a 6070 spy theory gizelle
I'm into it that way he pitched but
she's not an actress so it was a little
bit of a far-fetched for me and then
yeah you were I was with you
surprisingly more
and then you brought in the we're
bringing out Jim Carrey and Ryan
Reynolds and Gosling so you lost me to
max I guess the first point stands were
with you on that one
on Twitter 53% win for China
32% Canada 15% Brazil very similar on
YouTube is Brazil are we doing fast and
furious because that's the line misses
brother I always think of that now I
don't think of any real Brazil things I
just do thing this is Brazil all right
great so we got the bus a lot of really
clever the the fans had a ton of ideas
they wanted Russell Crowe for Australia
now good dot for Israel German for
Australia that was almost for Mexico get
a little crop Maga from Israel
sure wants to do a third I wonder where
they go for they wanted mr. echo for
Nigeria but Adewale a cannoli a but
Sahni
that's my guess Wow good attempt whoa I
don't know if it was right I'm the worst
I have no idea all right here we go
question - it's our title fight guys
there's all been this talk of a Captain
Marvel is gonna help spur the the face
for a universe and that she'll be an
affinity and in infinity War part 2 or
Avengers 4 I don't know what they're
calling it - you haven't really
officially called it all I know is may
it phase four is very questionable what
movies are we gonna see in this new
phase from Marvel and we have a
world-class pitcher here as well as two
wonderful awesome pictures you just
proved let's pitch a Marvel phase four
movie post Avengers for part four Roth
what do we want to see ok I'm going
first very well so you have to imagine
that the whole world has opened up after
infinity world where you can do any kind
of films so why not we haven't seen a
rom-com yet though with a twist
so we open up and it's Scarlet Witch in
the vision right edits thank you good
yeah musical cousin
yeah that's our partner in crime and
it's literally like vision in sweaters
and basically all of the tropes of the
rom-com and they have you know he's
playing soccer and asking it's playing
soccer and soccer baby play basketball
Tony and the guy named Chad and Kat and
she got like a snarky best friend that
we've never met before but there's just
something a little off about it there's
just something that feels a little weird
and every time you hear a television
it's just a little too loud and
dissonant and you're not sure and the
timelines and the characters and what's
going on doesn't exactly match what
we've seen at the end of infinity war
we're just a little confused and every
time they wake up in the morning one of
them wakes the other one up and says
wake up and it's just a little over
intense and it starts to feel more and
more dissonant and weird and we come to
find out that mojo has actually
kidnapped them and because the whole
world is this is [ __ ] cool the whole
world is in chaos he's basically
kidnapped them and whit found a way to
hook so mojo basically I was like
television networks right and he's
hooked her in him into his network and
used her abilities against her and has
basically sent her into a dream world
that he's then broadcasting out in the
to the dimensions and it's basically
like he signed people up for Big Brother
starring Scarlet Witch and vision and
either getting a peek into the fantasy
life they have together meanwhile in
this world they're still trying to wake
up and figure it out and it's going
through all of the trips of the rom-com
when they start to figure it out they
realize he keeps throwing everything
that he has against them so they're
gonna have to fight more villains and
more villains and get distracted and
then he just starts sending through
different sort of iterations of her
relationship she's a soccer mom and they
have kid three kids they're in couples
counseling and they're just suddenly
they realized that in order to actually
get out of this they have to destroy
their effing world and go ape and they
have to go against their Avengers they
have to Fogo full-on unleashed vision
and Scarlet Witch like we have never
seen them because they've been held back
in all the movies
and tear the frickin world down they
have to tear down Tony in the basketball
court and cap all of the chats who have
been recast sufficiently throughout the
film all of the Chad's come back army
they have to rip the frickin world apart
to wake up and get out of it and they
wake up into the crumbles of the world
post infinity world into the empty cells
that they've been in and he's escaped
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah basically to play guys in it's
basically Marvel Hunger Games this guy
named the Beyonder teleports all the
heroes and all the villains to like
battle planet and basically drop some a
bunch of weapons is like go sort it out
and and what I want to do is just
embrace in phase four let's get rid of
individual titles I'm not excited for
ant-man the wasp I'm not excited for the
Inhumans I want the Marvel Universe to
be in every movie and this is going to
set the tone that we're essentially
redoing the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
an 8 episode 200 million dollar per
episode series that's going to reward
repeat viewings and and not be tied into
telling one character's story because
for me
what's exciting about Marvel movies now
is the relationships between the
different characters and the different
combinations are getting and I think
they're already doing this like
homecoming is a Spider Man Iron Man
movie Ragnarok is Thor and the Hulk
Civil War is not Captain America it's
everyone so let's just drop the pretense
and reward people who stuck with it for
this long like we all know who these
people are by now let's get all these
different mini groups and and different
like little alliances and little fights
and stuff like that and secret war is a
great opportunity to do that because you
can flesh out the villains more you can
team them up with each other all the
crappy villains give them some more
backstory redeem them you can team up
you know rocket and Iron Man spider-man
the Hulk vision and Drac
and then also plant the seeds for future
feature-length episodes of like while
they're all about a planet maybe that's
when the scrolls start to take over on
earth maybe they start replacing all the
superhero girlfriends you know Pepper
Potts and stuff like that so they come
back to that is where you can set up the
symbiote suit for spider-man so you were
basically setting in motion this
gigantic series where every episode that
you see at the theater is gonna be
important and it's gonna feature
whatever characters Marvel needs to tell
their story got it max your turn I
believe that by the time infinity war
part 2 comes out I'll be sick of seeing
all these characters on screen together
I think that going beggar does not mean
going better because the truth of the
Marvel Universe and the strength of the
Marvel Universe and the power of the
Marvel Universe that they don't flex the
way they should they flex a little but
they don't [ __ ] flex is the fact that
these characters are their own universes
the fact that the Crimson Dynamo was
like barely a villain and Iron Man to
piss you off it pissed me off he was
barely in the movie that's a big
character they have Mickey Rourke that
didn't use them yeah when you watch
spider-man homecoming suddenly the
vulture is the most interesting
character in the movie let me just say
that there are many opportunities like
this in the Marvel Universe many many
many and I want to say that the angle of
taking vision and doing something
similar to ru combat fan because if you
read the most recent run on vision where
it's the vision family and it's someone
out there tell me you read comics
someone someone tell me you read comics
it was so great and cool and great
comics I'm gonna go to a different
direction
so Hawkeye after this movie I want to
focus in on two characters also by the
way we're saying Marvel doesn't have the
rights to mojo
sounds pretty cool I know these next men
however well they they worked on a
negotiation this is a trade like
megasonic and loot on my trade select
this blue tongue max has some ideas
which is that there is another character
who can't have his own movie but by the
time infinity war 2 comes out his rights
will be up and he can have his own movie
I want to talk to you about a movie
called
Hulk I want to finally make a good
Marvel whole movie because that
character deserves a commend not world
Hulk take that down I'm talking about
comic book Hulk baby I'm talking about
[ __ ] up Bruce David Banner he is a
messed up man
here's how the movie starts Hawkeye is
being airlifted into a city
Hulk is going crazy we witness a Hulk
tantrum destroying [ __ ] breaking [ __ ]
throwing [ __ ] down from the perspective
of three people Hawkeye a paramedic and
a teacher who has to evacuate her class
and her husband is somewhere in the city
and she's on the phone with him like
what the [ __ ] is going on with you
meanwhile Bruce Banner wakes up he's in
a strange place he doesn't recognize him
then he realizes it's his childhood home
his mother and his father are arguing in
the other room and he tries to stop them
as an adult that they don't listen in
fact when he grabs his father and says
no listen to me his father goes roar
like that sends him flying backwards
he's in a Giro del Toro night and
Guillermo del Toro nightmare version of
Bruce banners brain and we've been there
in the comic but we've never been there
in a movie and we have the technology to
do it and it can be incredible as
Hawkeye in the city struggles to follow
a rampaging Hulk and we witness what
it's like to be in a Marvel movie from
the perspective of normal people inside
of Bruce Banner he has to go on a tour
of all of his psychic trauma and you
know what that means that means finally
in a movie we get the professor the
maestro Jill fix it
savage gray Hulk everybody who lives
inside of Bruce Banner as he basically
goes through cognitive behavioral
therapy as shown in the classic fun
silly crazy Marvel Way of these movies
where
essentially dealing with deep dark
damage and Bruce's life except for its
him talking to [ __ ] Joe fix it in the
1930s bar I'm having to go toe-to-toe
with him you get Mark Ruffalo acting his
ass off what you have here is a
combination of the Marvel tone with
something a little bit deeper something
a little bit rich or something a little
bit more fun it's not quite the Marvel
Charlie Kaufman brilliance of the vision
pitch but it is Marvel meets the
impossible it's Marvel meets adaptation
it's going inside of a character and
letting that character be the movie
instead of relying on a bunch of
crossovers you know how many Hulk's
there are seven devil hope was in one
storyline and they never used him well I
want to use him in this he's [ __ ]
scary Bruce banners mind is the most
interesting thing about him and when you
have a character like an actor like Mark
Ruffalo who can get inside that
character and make you love him you can
do powerful stuff in this movie alright
guys I mean you guys were against
crossovers but you both put crossovers
in your movie you've got Hawkeye nears
in seven different hulks and you've got
the vision and Scarlet Witch
oh come on the vision and Scarlet Witch
is such a focused movie it's basically
the vision and Scarlet Witch and fantasy
versions of the Avengers that are
surreal that's what the Avengers in
their dream of its subverting the truth
especially even when you get into the
third act it's playing with the idea
that the third act is the same epic
battle scene because this time vision
and Scarlet Witch are both hero and
villain at once they are using the full
force of their powers which they are the
two most powerful to be able to
literally rip the freakin world apart
imagine the scale of that never seen
their worlds at stake I'm sorry guy who
just pitched secret
anything different this is marvelous
thank it's not about the world is at
stake it's about the people that you are
seeing as heroes you need to kill
basically their friends themselves their
lives in order to wake the Frick up that
is something that we have and when they
do what they wake up into is freaking
darkness also what's so insane and would
never have going to therapy and getting
beat by his dad like it's just not a
local movie yes it is have you been
watching the Marvel movies they're
getting pretty [ __ ] up guardians of
galaxy tune was like I murdered your
[ __ ] mom now I'm David Hasselhoff I
was like okay I think we're gonna be
okay with my level of darkness in
tomorrow what does he could use Tony's
machine basically gone awry machine your
pitch is basically Secret Wars was cool
all the tones of the same movie let's
just admit it movie the movie some of
them are slightly different we're
talking about what would we like to see
the whole world's could open up after
this they could do different kinds of
movies they could create something that
is completely innovative yes maybe they
want to get butts in seat because they
see it's working with other Studios to
do things that are different yes in
comic book movies maybe they want to get
a little bit interesting after this and
this is a way to do it that gives them
the opportunity to do multiple genres in
one movie that they have never done
before
and that frankly we as the audience
would love to see and has precedents
people want different stuff
people love different stuff well the
precedent for me isn't so much Marvel
movies or Secret Wars it's something
like Game of Thrones where like we want
to see these big events and we can
follow these complex stories with
millions of characters there
Ward's checking in once twice three
times a year to see where their paths
cross
obviously the different combinations of
them oh these two finally met up Oh
what's going on over here like we as an
audience we can take that and it's
rewarding to stick with characters for
so long and not be tithing like well I
don't really care about dr. strange I'm
gonna skip that one this one would every
single Marvel movie in phase 4 will be
appointment viewing because it would
have the possibility to have every
character if everything is appointment
viewing nothing is appointment viewing
your peach pinching season 7 of Game of
Thrones where things we've been waiting
down because it said no scenes hundred
Marvel movies we're in season seven of
Marvel the workplace sitcom where
everyone punches each other let's admit
they say it's a giant line running TV
show admit it we I don't know if you
know this but me Roth have been given
the power to create whatever movie I am
not bound by Marvel's corporate
prerogative and I get to try to pitch
something I want to see actually that
any senior wants to see so any I don't
bind me to China buddy all right
last thoughts I want it let's let's do
it real quick final I want to go through
why you got like the other one so why
don't we like Spencer Civil Secret Wars
pitch Ross max more the same yeah I mean
to me I cuz I adore Spencer by [ __ ] is
more just sort of a generic like and
things for the movies should be unique
but we actually pitch two of those
movies that would go in your program
because they unique they are specific
they focus on characters and they are a
different way of telling a story that
still creates in my case it's a fun it's
an epic Marvel movie it Avengers yet
okay why don't we want to see devil Hulk
Max's pitch Spencer in Roth you're
talking you were talking we don't want
to see his pitch because it just goes a
little bit too dark you know I mean I
think that people love the Hulk and that
what we've seen over the last several
movies is that yes it was a licensing
and rights issue but the Hulk ultimately
works best when he's set against other
characters when we get inside just the
Hulk's brain there's not a lot of a lot
that we want out of that we want the
Hulk to exist the way he does as a
support system we don't want to see him
in horrible trauma that's what Tony is
for yeah the Hulk is a
is a dark character and he's pretty much
a bad guy he's an out-of-control monster
and the movies when he has a solo movie
always have to bend over backwards to
justify why he's destroying everyone and
everything around him what she do you're
setting half the movie inside his head
and meanwhile he's killing families and
paramedics and kids are being airlifted
out like I'm gonna stop caring about the
hardly rooting actively rooting against
the Hulk at that point you're just so
weird why don't we like you don't have
mojo I think that like do you really
lost the thread of the rom-com not
you're talking about something that is
able to play with and against genre if
you're talking about so people have been
buying Hulk comics for about 70 years he
works as a solo character Max and
Spencer against my thing against Roth's
is that while being incredibly clever
while being incredibly cool while
letting us in these characters in a
different way all it is in the trailer
is a cool first minute and the second
minute of a Marvel movie it's his movie
again for the second half right it's
yours is a one twist pony
once the twist happens then it then it
you had a CGI Chad army like it just
turns into a nice you are the ones who
and I think you guys betrayed yourselves
by knocking me for crossovers while also
including the Avengers and on every
other Hulk and all these other Marvel's
all the other Hulk's are still just Hulk
buddy that's the cool thing about the
Hulk comic Marvel has its defending
myself alright Wow there was a lot of
strong distaste for Ross pitch at first
but I have never seen in a single round
a turnaround like this to where she
ended up I don't want to give away the
numbers but she ended up being that's
not a favorite than at least a lot of
support so a really good job of arguing
herself out of that one a lot of
comparisons to Charlie Kaufman and Wes
Anderson coming up during the animal
sunshine of the spotless vision
a lot of people in the YouTube comments
wanted max to know they do read comics
they do love comics and a lot of support
for this new vision run which is getting
its operating oh good you should read it
you'd love it I would love it I read I
sort of do recommendations I read a lot
of vertigo why are we doing this right
well check it out yeah all right on a
couch any quick thoughts where where
your heads
I wonder who would be directing those
movies well didn't say given I can see
Ross working the most I could see that
being word of mouth that this is a
different take in the get butts and the
seats to go see it yeah I feel like both
max and Roth give us two different take
that's more interesting and I do think
Spencer they got you and that it just
this it's the same is what we're gonna
go did come down to max and Roth and I
do think I do this is tough for me but I
do think I heard a little bit more
against you max just that it's so dark
and just the justifying why he's bad on
these things like it's it really it is a
good story I get it but I feel like yeah
but I I even you were almost giving too
much credit to Roth during her pitched
which felt it was your father
I just think Ross was surprisingly the
fact that she was able to turn and make
that actually it sounds so good I say
pray for mojo
let's do it
I do want to see your movie max but yeah
movies are really cool and they're both
a more grounded character side
intellectual YouTube actually agrees
with you forty-four percent our vision
scarlet which 39 went for wild Hulk 15%
for Marvel new dawn or secret war or
what we're calling it different on on
Twitter 42% went for secret war 30% for
the Hulk pitch and then only 28% Wow I
was with Spencer on that Hulk movie like
[ __ ] with Russell of acting that was
your best - you have like scenes with
him yes fastest you've always been weak
give me the keys for just a few days but
you might as well get weird yes oh you
went we're in a great way we all wanted
to see it alright question number three
this is gonna be another barn burner I
can already tell what movie is the best
improvement over its original source
material now that means it could have
been a book a video game a TV show etc
just needs to have been made prior to
the movie in some form another
we are back we're now to you Spencer
you're up first it's die hard yeah
that's right
it's an adaptation of a book a boring
ass book called nothing lasts forever
and this movie made the movie made a
couple key changes instead of rescuing
his wife and his marriage he's rescuing
his daughter instead of Hans Gruber it's
little Tony Gruber a world war two pilot
that you knew from back in the day
instead of talking to a sergeant al
Powell on the radio he's talking to a
stewardess he met on the plane and
instead of a the twist of like you think
they're terrorists but turns out they're
actually thieves no they really are
terrorists I think for all the changes
that they made improve the movie but
most of all it's just a fact of the Jean
or of the medium do you want to read
about a guy trapped in a skyscraper
fighting terrorists or do you want to
watch a guy escaping a skyscraper and
filled with terrorists it just made
turning this into a movie elevated it's
so much and that is why it is die hard
max we pickin
have you read the book that I read and I
didn't finish it no I read the Wikipedia
no I read that I opened that I was like
this is so uh-huh
so I've read a book called Fight Club
and while you were all 16 once we were
also all 17 and we saw the movie I have
to say if you've read Fight Club period
the end the movie is a better experience
in the book the book is up its own ass
it trades on the sarcastic misogyny
within itself in a sincere way the book
like proffers itself as an actual piece
of philosophy whereas the philosophy in
the movie is entirely a tongue-in-cheek
joke offered to us by a psychopath the
twist works better in the movie the
Marla characters more interesting unless
of a joke in the movie the narrator's a
better character in the movie and also
the movie is fundamentally visual as
good of a writer as chuck panic is the
fights in the book are just words and
they're boring and they're badly written
and I know that because I've read Fight
Club boys I read it I thought it was
great cuz I was 16 and I went back to it
the twist works better literally
everything that's in the book Fight Club
is just better shorter funnier smarter
more intellectually executed in a movie
that has one of the best Brad Pitt
performances if not the best Brad Pitt
performance incredible costume design
incredible cinematography hilarious
editing the editing in Fight Club is
brilliant and they change ultimately
very little they just put out all the
bad stuff and make the parts that were
like cringy like men's rights into a
joke and the book like had its tongue a
little bit in its cheek but the movie
takes it all the
there and mates the sardonic mean anger
of the book into fun light commentary
combat comedy in a way that is brilliant
even a guy getting the [ __ ] beat out of
him and bleeding on another guy is
presented almost as a scene of slapstick
it's great Fight Club holds up I'm
saying this because I saw it a week ago
I'm going with The Silence of the Lambs
which is a book that is fine and was
well received actually when it came out
and it's a good read I have read the
Silence of the Lambs like multiple times
actually as a child's because dark but
this is a book that was okay but
ultimately kind of be treated or plain
read whatever throwaway turned into one
of the most iconic movies of our time
you have these performances you have how
many times have you quoted Silence of
the Lambs the film on day to day how
many times have you been Buffalo Bill on
a date last night
[Laughter]
I don't want to make it weird
yes I was there yes yeah mother's good
this one all five Academy Awards this is
a film that people have tried to repeat
and in fact they tried to repeat with
these characters sadly and it only
worked in the television show this was a
perfect marriage of actor to character
and not just one role which sometimes
happens with three in that movie and
I'll let you guess which the third one
is it's Buffalo Bill Clarice Starling
and
yes obviously head of the FBI Scotland
he's good to know he's great in that
movie you're talking about a film that
he's another guy who jerks off brick
it's a guy that jerks off and throws to
come
a book that is fine turning into a
classic film that is ultimately it's
visual in a different way right I think
that I love Fight Club but it's
definitely very overtly using the tools
and this is something that's relying on
pacing and it's relying on the
performances and it's relying on tension
and it's very subtle filmmaking in a way
as compared to Fight Club and
particularly but particularly but these
are both completely elevated versions of
the source material this one's just a
little bit more so it's taking sort of a
lesser book and making a greater film
five Academy Award silence the Lambs on
Dyer it's fine perfect movie okay for
what it is perfect what it is it's a
perfect absolutely absolutely but your
tie are we already fighting yeah let me
just say Fight Club uses the language of
the book more intelligently than either
of these Fight Club uses the language of
the book to make a great movie whereas
literally uses the language of the book
they pull the gun introduce it by adding
stuff what do you added subtracted what
you guys are talking it cuts out bad and
adds the language of film what you guys
are talking about both of yours both of
your adaptations are adaptations that
essentially do an amazing job adopting a
book mine is something that does
something both read your books multiple
times I barely read mine twice okay I
did it where do you talk about like the
hearts you and you and me we're all like
pretty savvy film viewers and you like
talk about how Fight Club is full of
humor and how they're in on the joke the
joke of Fight Club went over everyone's
head every Freddy mikeg Stan with the
Fight Club poster on their dorm room
does not get the joke of Tyler Durden
the movie presented him as the cool guy
that everybody wants to be you didn't
get that whereas in the book you can
tell he's the villain you can tell that
it's ironic that people are just trading
consumer fascism
actual fascism and the movie is totally
lost on people it made it way to M so
now you're pitching lady Caulfield does
that your Catcher in the Rye you're
talking about the failure of the
audience at all I first of all die hard
while being a great and yeah and your
writing don't was an adaptation thank
perfect action movie it is a hundred
percent you're you're comparing that to
something that is one of the most
beloved movies in total of all time it
may be a perfect movie in total not just
of its genre in total we're talking
about three grand film or perfect in the
other two films is that what you're
saying Tran saying I'm saying it's a
very different film than the other two
films I'm seeing by clips from the other
two yeah Fight Club direness Islands in
the lands are what to help us hearing
what's the best improvement over its
original source material that's the
question here to help rein us in the
greatest improvement in my mind is a
hundred percent Silence of the Lambs
Silence of the Lambs
is a decent book it's a okay it's a
pulpy good read okay then you put it
down this is a movie that stays with you
this is a movie that has stayed with all
of cinema since it was made this is a
movie that people are chasing this is a
movie that people are trying to catch
and redo and they can't they never can
okay Spencer how again why is this a
better improvement at or improvement I
mean I think that when you're talking
about an action movie or an action story
the medium limits it you don't want to
read about an action story just by
presenting the same thing visually you
get so much more involved in it and by
doing these by getting Bruce Willis and
Alan Rickman to do these performances
you're so much more invested in
characters who on the page are
two-dimensional so just by virtue of
making a movie out of this book elevates
it in a way that and any book is limited
by by these scenes that a movie actually
pulls off max everything Spencer just
said is true but at the end of the day
he's talking about a movie that
ultimately was a straight adaptation of
its book I'm talking about a movie that
used the language of literature to do a
movie in in a way that hadn't been done
and
the film iconic not just a good movie
but a movie that changed the way movies
are I mean silence was that too but
silence was ultimately a serial killer
thriller die hard is a perfect action
movie there really hasn't been another
movie like Fight Club
other than Fight Club that pulled off
that tone that tone being able to take
that time every David Fincher movie what
yeah nihilism darkness or I'm a man wait
why are we comparing Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo to Fight Club in tone yes
tone in language they are completely
different Michael it's a [ __ ] comedy
it's dark there's a blue haze filled
room people are nihilistic Roger Twitter
my god sounds of the Lambs
is not just a thriller it really isn't
Silence of the Lambs is one of the most
interesting and beloved love stories of
our time it is one of the more did they
let her be gay it's one of the weirdest
stories of two people loving one another
inappropriately terrifyingly
understanding one another there's no one
in the world that Clarice is more
intimate with and then Hannibal and the
reverse is also true you don't see that
kind of relationship freaking anywhere
and that was not in the book the bones
of it was in the book but the life of it
came out in that movie and those
performances you know where else the
bones of it were in [ __ ] Manhunter
Silence of the Lambs as a signal during
the POS it's not good it's nice what I
tell you this movie elevated that
material I've seen Manhunter I've seen
all the versions this would be elevated
under a book the book it was red dragon
and yeah that's what I'm trying to say
yeah
again and then they did Hannibal my
point is that's what I'm trying to
illustrate here there were other
adaptations of these of that character
that didn't work and of his characters
that didn't work but this did this was
the largest improvement of those
characters of that writer and Hannibal's
also really good show the scale is
science the limbs it's a movie fight and
I'm saying that that is not necessarily
the greatest selection for an elevation
yeah well I think Silence of the Lambs
is stupid you did say that officially
final if I'm using my final thoughts max
anything because I'm actually club
changed movies it took a book that was a
hit that had a unique tone and a cool
perspective and a cool voice translated
that and enhanced it with performances
that became utterly iconic not simply
for being in a good movie but for being
in a different movie Fight Club was a
failure a flop that has maintained
because of its iconography and its power
failure
it has made because of its advertising
but it I could name other movies that
have suffered because of their
advertising but it made money primarily
it made its money back because of the
strength of it you're talking about two
huge studio releases of books that no
one's read and some people have read
Fight Club was a hit book and then a
movie that did something so different
and so special that it has become a
legend Spencer final thought yeah you
talk about hit books that became flops
like that's not an improvement and I
find that the fact that so many people
misunderstand the movie Fight Club
is testament to like the fact that the
book might be a little better it's a
little more clear-cut actually to me
where the dynamics are and what he's
trying to say
I don't think Fight Club is a is a
clear-cut improvement and sounds to the
lamps they're both so good that if the
yes the performances are iconic but it
doesn't elevate it to the point where
you take a a verge novel to a perfect
action movie that's
you're talking about that picture that's
not anything I the Internet's an
overwhelming support on this question
for Jaws there's tons of man that nobody
picked John's other other selections
super Starship Troopers came up a lot
psycho The Shining two shining came up a
lot especially yeah The Godfather and
Princess Bride those were the other big
ones and I saw but people also really
did not like Spencer saying that they
don't get Fight Club they feel like
they're getting fight gloves very clear
thing mud the opposite of mother only
fact is its MiG's MiG's is the guy in
the cell next to Clarice name is MiG's
what did you think they're lon wow
that's a tough one this is okay well let
make sure you're a little bit i cards
and i want see where you chime in
because they don't scimitar tammy the
question is what movie is the best
improvement over its source material
right I feel like sadly they all sort of
admitted no one's read Spencer's book
it's a terrible book and they've all
admitted how great died art is whereas
flight club even Max's minutes great
book we're off asthma it's a great book
I almost feel like just in the process
of elimination die hard the book is
clearly from the movie is clearly the
best improvement thought how could you
say that
III thought the one I mean I I agree
with you overall I think the one thing
that Spencer did that was very smart was
actually go to the book and say here's
an Elliot from the book that wasn't Tony
we are terrorists and I am Larry just a
for the record I 100% agree with max my
club is a terrible book in a great movie
but I feel like Spencer made the case
better for here are the specific things
that were in for you know I mean I think
Max and Ross both made really strong
arguments too and Max you did point out
how hard how harder it is to do but I
don't know because I'm grasping at
straws here at best improvement over its
source material I think Spencer wins off
this semantic victory is the only way to
grasp it Spencer gets that point I don't
like Trump because he's an anti polls so
on YouTube right now they're saying
Spencer wins with 42% for die-hard there
are close to 40% for Fight Club 17% said
Silence of the Lambs is the champion max
on Twitter like diehard also wins 43%
Fight Club 34% silence 23% so for buzz
all right here we got a question for in
honor of the lego ninjago movie we want
you to improve a movie by turning it
into a lego movie this came in from WWE
J th one Jeremy Thank You Jeremy so it's
an existing movie how what would
existing movie be better if I had been a
lego movie instead we're back to you max
there you know what sucked 2012 it was a
bad movie it was a stupid movie the
premise of the movie was stupid look at
the picture you're seeing right now
already watching the movie with Woody
Harrelson and is [ __ ] pickles but I'm
telling you I've chosen a terrible movie
would be unbelievably funny and instead
of it being the end of the world it
would be a huge lego city and people are
moving out of a house and the Legos have
been left behind
so there's flooding and then the house
is torn down and it's the end of a lego
world as experience through the eyes of
Lego John Cusack I want you to go on
them freaking internet and watch scenes
from 20 pub a limo going through LA as
it falls apart it's better if there were
jokes happening it's better if Lauren
Miller owning a plane taking off as the
entire world stops existing under it
it's funnier if like under that it's
like shag carpeting and when go men are
falling into the shag carpeting like
it's lava and going out I'm so tangled
but you're still alive no leave me I'm
too tangled I have a dead spider is next
to me like it's so funny the idea of
Legos in an abandoned house that's
falling apart having to deal with the
end of their world and the fact that
he's a limo driver and the movie is so
stupid
what happens to my dad's voice somehow I
like become like this guy I know why it
happens I'm sorry but 2012 sucks and if
it was a lego movie it would be if one
Miller made a 2012 movie in the Lego
universe win that tone it would be
freaking incredible period the end all
right my man Ross you're next I am going
with Jurassic world and this is the
reason if you look at what Jurassic
world is and here's my pitch for Dan
side-by-side of Jurassic Park and
Jurassic world it is basically Jurassic
Park with the addition of Chris Pratt
and somebody running around the jungle
in heels removal of all the characters
removal of the character dynamics right
so instead of doing that in live-action
why not do that in the lego movie in
which it makes sense to simply redo the
plot of the previous movie and get
self-reflexive about it and make fun of
the fact that you are in a world in
which you keep returning to the same
freakin part and the same frickin
problem again and again and again and
again you can't get out of it suddenly
that's a brilliant movie suddenly that's
a movie that's making fun of franchises
that's making fun of sequels
movie in which you have little Lego
dinosaurs fighting and the whole world a
possibility opens up and you can still
get Chris Pratt to voice that damn movie
anyway
all right Spencer all right yeah I'm
doing something kind of similar to ruff
together taking a bad movie thank you
all but yeah so I'm just gonna get right
to it it's the Lego Phantom Menace and I
think that what you want out of a lego
movies you want to be an example of the
genre but also be like a self-aware
parody version of that genre at the same
time and what I'm missing from your guys
that I want to do is to have the framing
devices to have like you had Will
Ferrell and his kid in this one you have
a guy who loved the prequels a pretty
cool defender and a guy who loved the
originals who only want Star Wars to be
exactly the same and they are playing
re-enacting trying to improve Phantom
Menace with their Legos and it's a
commentary on oh we need new stuff we
need new original ideas to be in Star
Wars whereas one guy just says no I want
more obi-wan I want it to be more like
the more like Luke in that dynamic and
they're acting out it's like this I
don't know if they're father and son but
it's the relationship of wanting
something new or wanting to retreat to
the familiar told throughout the story
of the Phantom Menace
your Funny or Die sketch about Legos
sounds great smashing what you built I
want to do and by the way you say
there's no framing device I put them in
a house that's being torn down
that's the framing device they're
constantly gags involving [ __ ] in the
house like like how things gonna be a
giant tidal wave is like sweeping down
with none that also when it's all Legos
it's just the visual spectacle and all
of that is blame and maybe you're gonna
be eventually later but it's just Legos
falling apart no no no no no no have you
seen no lego movie that movie is
beautiful you're like saying the lego
movie is ugly I don't know what world
you're ever Sam it's not as beautiful as
2012 is when Jess
there's money 12 looks like a video game
from 2004 I know I'm being facetious but
the thing is that he's just watching
Legos fall apart and John Cusack scream
it was bad driving the limousine for a
destroyed lego city like a Los Angeles
and also like 2012 of course you don't
because if there are jokes during he's
like the richest guy in the world he has
a full dollar bill that's why just stop
him a Lego figures hand oh my god it's
so much bigger than the rest of the
money it's just a good idea Funny or Die
sketch here pitching disaster movies no
2012 already was disaster movie I'm
pitching 2012 with Legos and your movie
I just don't wanna watch Jurassic world
again and I would say this that the only
thing that 2012 had going on for it was
the ridiculousness of that spectacle and
the wildly ridiculousness of that
spectable that's just really literally
all there is why bother making a lego
movie about that why bother making
anything about that ever again the point
of the lego movie is that it's riffing
on things that exist it's making
commentary about film it's not a film
that we really need any commentary on
whereas Jurassic world suddenly you take
this thing that lifted the plot of a
previously existing if you loved movie
that with characters that we can all
hook into and freaking dinosaurs and you
are commenting on the film you are
commenting on the industry you're
commenting on franchise yeah but don't
think there's about a different there's
not enough risk for that mill like
there's one good dress apart movie and
you can only taste say oh we're on the
perfect and one and a half I like three
I'm not sure that that framing does
device really works because first of all
you're assuming that that's necessary
whereas in Lego Batman there was no such
framing device they didn't just lift
that again then you're just trying to
kind of redo what they did in the lego
movie there's so many Batman things and
Trump's to draw on and same with Star
Wars plus you get to sell all the Star
Wars toys all over again here's a
problem with your pitch they're already
doing that and if you want to see the
characters from Phantom Menace in Lego
you can buy them already in fact you can
play a video game the lego franchise has
been tied in with the Star Wars
character by John Cusack's limo I'm
shaking you're pitching something that
already exists like it's new and you
haven't got inventory charger many
things are sitting punch you are pitches
pitching a thing that exists like it's
new
that's what Lego is all about it's this
movie is about the compromise between
the old and the new and finding harmony
for like yeah let's keep doing the old
stuff but in new ways I think there's
actually a message here that people
might latch on so what you're saying is
you want more Star Wars movies but the
other thing that doesn't make sense
totally to me in terms of how the movie
even functions is that when you were in
the Lego movies it's not like they were
aware that they were being played with
you know they were they were autonomous
missions and the dad until the end and
they don't know that until then they
don't get that reveal so you're actually
an assumption is that these are my
father and son playing fine you were see
because at the end he's like don't mix
up my Legos it's what the whole movies
you are suggesting a movie with no
stakes that by its premise is watching
two people play with toys and have an
argument that people have been having
online for the last 20 yea dramatized
and yours is a bunch of Legos falling
apart yeah in a cool way
okay it's cool and funny
my work says actual the way the Lego
movies work is to do exactly what I am
suggesting doing it's amazing
to comment I couldn't tell which were
the joke responses this is actual
pitches but a few of my favorites Fifty
Shades of Grey came up so much I think
they actually should do it
emoji movie requiem for a dream show
girl's mother came up my mother would be
prettier would be a lot of people had
actually made the point that max ended
up making a lot that they feel like
maybe Jurassic Park it's Star Wars
because they already have so many lego
properties out there we're questioning
the wisdom of those selected for Batman
thing uh here's my problem though I
didn't hear them really take down Ross
at all all I heard was Max and Spencer
taking each other out a lot I thought it
was a pretty clever concept there and
you get Chris Pratt back cuz he's Emmet
that's well I mean we mother a minute or
not you're getting he's done that's
thing same park same problems being for
the sequels guys in the couch to anyone
have a strong point of view from someone
else I think okay you have the mic yeah
quickly I thought that max made a really
good point I would I would say that
movie better than 2012 the original yeah
out of these three I feel like I would
most want to watch the 2012 Lego
Destruction film yeah I mean you did and
you did point out the fact that we've
seen these in games it is we've sorry
well you said Phantom Menace didn't
wrestle well but that I they did make a
drastic world game I too didn't they
everything is a game oh there's a Lego
Jurassic world game yes you're a sick
part I think you see
it was the same time I believe you play
through the three jar add the first
three Jurassic Park films in the game
Alan yes so you're off picking max I
like max the basket cm I was it wasn't
Spencer cuz I do think you ended up just
doing uh I don't know it's the same
argument we've heard which max made so
that gives an edge to max for me it's
basically you're watching the internet
argue about Star Wars and format move
that does sound interesting but then the
more I thought about it now we can see
that anywhere Jurassic world which one's
funnier I guess is where I'm trying to
figure out they're kind of all Funny or
Die sketches in a weird way I'm gonna
give slight edge then based on what are
the fans vote very very close on Twitter
right now 35 percent Phantom Menace 34
percent twenty twelve thirty one percent
Jurassic world there's a bigger
difference on YouTube 58 percent like
twenty twelve twenty eight percent like
Phantom Menace 13 percent dressing
alright
based on I'm just cuz I'm having trouble
because I would probably watch them all
away I'm gonna go with the consensus
there and go twenty twelve max what's
that point that was close
[Applause]
it's 2017 you guys are kid I mean you're
all tied tied except for that one points
that point mired in this round that's
gonna get interesting here we go we're
doing a blind fight as when we told you
guys I want you each to pick a movie
with great characters are you write down
your movie with great characters write a
name down here pick a movie with great
characters you can take a car that's all
I'm telling you with great characters
claim is that you don't know what the
question the audience at home already
knows what this question is gonna be and
you don't guess it's called a backwards
fight so you must pick a movie with
great characters the audience can see
now you guys can't we turned off the
television nice job Billy
this is this round for round five this
is what they'll be fighting and they
will have to defend the movie they picks
this is really throwing our best
fighters here we can I didn't watch the
event ask a question about this sure
should we choose a movie with you're not
signing anything with characters that
everyone would know so that it's easier
yeah let's not go obscure yeah
commercially popular it'll help if
everyone is familiar with it yes the
film would have seen is always helpful
and movie fights I keep going back and
forth but just a film with great
characters any scale you don't know what
the question is you have no idea what's
in go so just pick something but god
damn it I wrote down three and now I
don't get a cross one on yeah all right
I'm gonna give five seconds five four
three you got a movie you picked a movie
all right Spencer say your movie out
loud wolf of wallstreet the wolf of
Austria ruff Being John Malkovich
Malkovich and Max Star Wars Episode four
a new hope Star Wars Being John
Malkovich your tossing out show the
graphic oh we didn't know they did we
shall get back to the topic now is what
movies characters would you want as your
prison gang
[Applause]
respect your choice now you have a
moment to think about this you are yes
what movies characters would one you for
now that you and you can remember you
can use any of their characters yeah I
feel like there's a lot of characters
crawling like that's so many characters
it's not all that might be good or bad
for him so who wants to start yeah I'll
start what Wall Street I mean you're in
prison with people who have the most
connections on the outside people who
are who are rich who are slime balls who
are willing to do anything that's what
you want to be rolling deep in earth in
prison this isn't anything goes
cutthroat world you want an
anything-goes cutthroat gang that you're
rolling with you want people who like
know how to do criminal activities not
newbies you want it like a Jordan
Belfort guy who can smuggle in what's
the drug that they like yeah we can get
you women who can get you quaaludes who
can get you cocaine and who can build
you back up for nothing once you're on
the outside yeah so I than not choosing
jaw's than not choosing the Godfather
for this and what you picked
until I realized that I picked the movie
in which the people have the actual
technology and ability to get you to
freaking escape you can go into a
different body and take it over these
are the people that can get you out of
prison so why would I not want that to
be my prison gang in your mind no it
doesn't matter
the only part of you that's real Spencer
okay alright so the characters who all
go to prison and spend the entire movie
being scared of going to prison and then
their lives are ruined once they go to
prison and our bunch of self-centered
duplicitous [ __ ] are in prison with
you
you're probably not doing great the
characters who betray each other
constantly throughout the film in order
to escape their terrible lives and
establish one meaningful connection in
the whole movie via a portal on the
eight-and-a-half floor of a building
that you can't get to from prison versus
characters who do breakouts every movie
baby we get out of the dead stuff we get
out of the cloud city's fiasco Oh hand
didn't get out it's okay we go and we
get him to r2 as the light saber in his
head
first of all first of all first of all
holy [ __ ] how did I choose Star Wars
this is you have Luke Skywalker and
attuned force user you have Han Solo a
guy who's been to the most dangerous
places in the universe you have Leia
who's either a prisoner with you and you
know she's gonna send you into the
garbage chute and get you [ __ ] out of
the Death Star but do you also have
Darth in the there my prison gang Darth
Vader is on the same team with Han Solo
no this prison is [ __ ]
can you get me out of this prison he's
like like that then we walk out I'm like
here's your inhaler Darth and he thanks
me and he kisses me we don't and I fell
in love while we were in prison who is
my gang if he's in my and I'm his bill
that does being in the gang doesn't
always have to be positive or negative
so you guys can fight those both yes
doesn't mean that you're the leader of
the rock Fighters person [ __ ] I'd
rather do that than get [ __ ] by jordan
belfort john malkovich the actual
celebrity actual celebrity also got
actual celebrity person you guys are
hinging this all on the escape plan and
like the aggression of the gang you're
with you guys are overlooking an
important factor
Jordan Belfort and his gang are very
rich and very white we are going to the
most country club ass prison you've ever
been to just like in the movie we are
playing tennis we are getting catered
meals you're basically living the life
we lived on the outside but with an
ankle bracelet I will I would move to
the white-collar prison that they're in
awesome you are dealing with a group of
duplicitous sociopathic sycophants who
worship Jordan Belfort and backstab each
other gladly you are at the actual
bottom of that totem pole and those guys
are not fun to hang out with if I have
to hang out with obi-wan and Darth Vader
and Luke and daddy issues oh I'm gonna
park my sister
this is more fun than hanging out with a
bunch of cocaine mulanax [ __ ] party
in the in jail yeah this is it
Goodfellas connections they have
connections they lost all their money
and I don't know if you've ever been
with anybody that's coming down on
cocaine that is not pretty
mr. cements are talking about daddy
issues playing tennis they are gonna be
shaking in a corner there with a
puppeteer and a self-important neck with
a freaking Malkovich not only am I gonna
be intact i early and two stalkers of
John Malkovich is gonna be the weirdest
dynamic of a prison gang of all time we
don't know how many portals are we don't
know yes we do Redemption we're gonna
portal a new portal and even if we don't
I have it an actual celebrity to really
hook me up in prison and actually get me
all of the things and make it as a full
six months experience and then get my
ass out JJ Abrams is gonna make sure
that I have a safe smooth ride through a
Star Wars movie I've seen him do it
before he's gonna be out there Luke has
a few setbacks but at the end of the day
I got Scorsese you're you want to be
miss course as you move I want him in my
prison gang if you want to do this as a
movie you're getting beaten to buried in
the radio wax and you're getting talked
about having JJ in your prison we don't
know who's controlling the most
controlling you I am Mary Sue look
I'm playing paddle tennis with white
shorts every day no way that in reality
of those characters that Darth Vader
isn't destroying your world every single
day draw Nazi storm troopers destroy
every single character in Star Wars what
movies characters would you want as your
prison gang I mean they're they're not
only baby one your gang a positive or
negative if someone is in my gang by
default they're on my team that's what a
gang is inter damn friction gang getting
friction but I can trust my friend and
his dad single character be a part of
the positive part of the game that
doesn't work
Yahtzee yes I'm saying that doesn't work
his position would be so low there is
not a single character and being happy
about it I'd be above Greenall thank you
maybe you stand in your in your ranking
it's not a single character in Being
John Malkovich and I'm including John
Malkovich that I cannot manipulate there
is no possible you can't mean if you had
time Catherine Keener that is not true
Catherine can manipulate John Malkovich
no possible way that I am not at the
head of that game maybe right under John
Malkovich is still gonna be my best
friend and I'm that your best friend
just done virtue of I love you ruff but
what just because you're you Ross the
last person who tried to manipulate
their way to the head of that group of
people ended up trapped in John not get
your subconscious forever oh and by the
way what better place to be and who else
in the world who else in that world is
he gonna be friends with I'm insane
exactly so who does he have left to be
friends with they're just another
obsessed fan
which means that every single person in
that world as you admitted is so
sycophant ik obsessive weak nor masty
narcissistic mean I am a medium
okay human at that point yes that's
awesome
yeah medium okay human wins with him at
that point there's no way he's not my
best friend and there's no way I am not
getting all of the benefits of being
with a celebrity in jail alright final
thought Spencer you're in like
government rebellion Gitmo and you're in
like like stalker can happen federal
pound-me-in-the-ass prison I am in low
minimum security everybody's just like a
white-collar criminal like yeah okay
they're a jerk no one's nice in prison
but we're all rolling together we all
have hookups on the outside is the
easiest time you'll ever do Maxwell
thoughts we all took the type of prison
to be the a piece of our argument we all
did that and I started that but the
truth is that wasn't the [ __ ]
question we're talking about a real
normal prison he said prison gang I
didn't say what kind of prison as your
prison gang which is my prison gang the
Star Wars prison the Being John
Malkovich prison and the Jordan Belfort
prison you're now adding what movie
would you like to be in Yeah right Blum
you agree that's the are you sure I
actually think max is making a salient
point which is it's more fair if you say
just pick a general prison and then this
is your gang as opposed to different
prisons for different movies okay so
they can't make arguments against the
force then because that's we had this
argument before we did it and the force
winds by semantics and then not even
budgin
you have to leave all of your weapons
and abilities you don't get to keep them
you know what sure to set that you know
what let's just say that's true the
bottom line and my final thought is that
I would rather spend time with Luke
Skywalker Leia r2d2 Chewbacca Han Solo
then I would with a bunch of people who
literally hate each other to the degree
that they destroy each other and being
John Malkovich and a bunch of guys who
while it's fun to watch them [ __ ] models
on an airplane I don't think I could
spend 30 there are those are the tough
guys people think I am like I wouldn't
spend 30 seconds with those guys without
wanting to kill myself I'd like to add
one thing to my argument if we're not
gonna do the prison type of prison if
that doesn't man fair okay Jordan
Belfort can sell his way into anything
we're gonna have the best run prison
economy sell me this pen he's gonna have
a new cigarettes he's gonna be coming
and getting every single prison perk out
of every single other prison employee
until we're on the top of that prison
there's no possible way that I am NOT
gonna get more perks by being John
questions where does it go so I guys in
the couch there's any quick favorites
quickly I did like a lot of people in
social media stuck to like they answered
before they saw the question it's stuck
to it so we had chicken parmesan had to
argue that brick killed a guy so
anchorman would be good and neo Varma
nadir argued Oh - excuse me George had
argued fantastic mr. Fox and they get
stuck arguing like you'd have a lot of
animal friends you know to keep you
occupied in there well I mean I think we
came down to the points I saw he'd be
friends with actual John Malkovich and
how much
the best sells the pen probably gets all
the all the access I I do think before
we changed which prison you are you made
a very salient argument of you'd be in
the country-club prison which would
probably be the cushiest of any of these
prisons but max you did do you mean your
strongest point for me was the variable
you made at the end of who would you
rather spend time with these sort of
more iconic characters whereas all these
people sort of hate each other and be
sort of miserable to be stuck in it but
so well I'm gonna have to say I gotta
give it to Spencer I just I thought
there was too much funny creative things
you picked and while yours is the
obvious choice I thought you were up
against the wall between him how much of
a Salesman he'd be what kind of prison
he'd be those things sent me over the
edge so Spencer gets the final point
yeah that puts max and Spencer into the
finals but Wow fantastic so now you're
gonna help me decide pics should have
picked jaws and luck of the draw are
you're gonna help me decide here which
these speed round so please pay
attention we have five speed round
questions you both are tied here we go
question one you have the clock you good
lon I'm all set in honor of James Gunn
getting his own Funko figure what
unlikely actor or director that doesn't
have one we can spot check for you
deserves their own Funko darren
aronofsky every single one darren
aronofsky okay
[Music]
hmm okay they probably have everyone I
think it's safe to say oh that's fine he
does not does not have max you're up
first can you have first you have 20
seconds when you begin speaking there's
already enough Tommy Wiseau merchandise
in the world he has his own movie coming
out very few people understand how silly
Darren Aronofsky looks and yes it's
Carson is silly thing I would love to
have it in my house it would be
hilarious Darren Aronofsky is a
wonderful filmmaker his films are
divisive and brilliant and I want him to
be a toy that I can make fight Darth
Vader okay Spencer your argument your
argument bringing up how Darren
Aronofsky looks all Funko pops look the
same he's gonna look like spider-man or
whatever with a scarf you won't be able
to tell who it is Tom who so at least
has the hair that you can latch on to
and yes he does have a movie coming out
it's a perfect time to release his own
line of action figures you can totally
do the voice which everyone loves to do
well oh hi mark nobody knows what an
autopsy sounds like he's not fun to play
with you're gonna play with him but you
doing a play and reenact your own little
time as Oh movies most fun thing about
it being Darren Aronofsky is that it can
be any film director it looks like a guy
with glasses in the store you can direct
all your other Funko's if it's Tommy
wise though you can only do roam games
and I got bored of rune gank so if my
mom said that they were too dirty
because of all the thrusting out of
contr you can totally have Tommy was
owed director
I draw any other Spencer just took it
for the finale all right you got that
point Spencer in honor of the upcoming
documentary about him improve no
difference no no in honor of the
upcoming documentary about him improve
any film by replacing the lead actor
with Gilbert Godfrey in honor of his new
documentary Gilbert an evil by replacing
the lead actor with Gilbert do whatever
you want
mmm improve a film by adding taking it's
leaked out and substituting with Gilbert
Godfrey you got it he's waiting Spencer
max anybody Mad Max fury road farmers
dark of the Moon which actor see
replacing Shyam and your he's Tom Hardy
okay time starts meeting Mad Max fury
road is a story of a man slowly
regaining his voice entertain and have
fun and actually interesting would it be
to have him largely be silent and
speaking in grunts but to slowly regain
his Gilbert Godfried Ness the movies
still the same it's still the great
action but his grunts and stay with it
Tom Hardy stuff that we've heard a
million times is actually among oh oh my
god again great Funny or Die video but I
would pay cash money to see a
full-length version of Transformers Dark
of the Moon with Gilbert Gottfried as a
lead with no dialogue changed and all
the other actors
exactly the same optimist why don't we
go okay because I saw it it's the best
idea ever
if minds have fun your dice catch yours
just like an editing mistake like guys
Gilbert Godfried in this at least mine
like you can sort of by him as opposed
to puck lipstick survivor more than top
model he looks like he has radiation
poisoning ten seconds I believe you
haven't seen Mad Max terrible version of
it I'm pitching a version of Dark of the
Moon that would be better the end run
out the clock not using the clock all
right Ross based on those arguments um
it's the only it's wahlberg in dark of
the moon right it wasn't shy i would see
that one that's one guys transformers
all the way yeah okay there we go you're
back in this max were tied again number
three in honor of max's thesis a scar no
one else can see in what movie should
have a theme song written and performed
by carly rae jepsen lasting movie what
movie should have a theme song performed
by Carly Rae Jepsen may I ask you a
question about the question you want do
you want a theme song that fits the most
profound discovery and pop music you
want haven't won that she would kill I
want the best what movie should have a
theme song written and performed color
Jepson yeah well I'd like one that fits
the jefferson pattern though okay if we
can do okay I can do that give me a
second Chronicle
[Laughter]
all right what movie you pick in she
might be watching max you got five
seconds during Aronofsky's mother oh
there we go
that's waiting for that to be ended
somewhere Chronicle first go ahead
Spencer I know the one song she's a pop
star yeah no she is okay Carly Rae
Jepsen writing the theme song to
Chronicle you have like all these
teenagers who are experiencing so much
angst that's perfect material for a pop
song and then she could like weave in
these secret layers of like maybe about
someone that's like obsessed with her
and she could be like warning them that
she's like gonna take out a restraining
order like she could be doing this it
works on multiple levels because it's
about it's about not wanting these
teenagers to next 20 seconds there is no
score in Chronicle there would be no
place for a theme song mother is filled
with score throughout is a lyrical movie
about obsession rejection and misery the
pain of wanting someone you can't have
and Carly can make that a lot of fun
just like darren aronofsky does in his
real silly movie mother alright now I
want a title of her song in this last 10
seconds I'll do you better I'll sing it
I haven't met you but you seem crazy I'm
not giving you my number don't call me
ever
max I tent that with I think that'd be
weird and the title would be frozen
heart I agree I do think it would be
weird I want to just give props for
being hilarious but that actually made a
lot more ya guys
anyone voting for Spencer yeah why don't
you have the next question about like
what happened to my bar mitzvah question
for what song would be the best for
Spencer's Bar Mitzvah that would be
worldly matters by which which franchise
should Linda Hamilton join post
terminator wait he's coming back for
terminator three she's coming back James
Cameron produced Tim Miller directed
she's coming back for that what should
she do next
Terminator 3 she's gonna be yeah she's
cuz they're basically retconning it like
everything after Judgment Day didn't
happen it's our new Terminator throwing
out David's landing bad I guess yes
wiping out the other ones but it's
technical six but yeah yes oh but after
she does that where do we want to see
Linda Hamilton join next
look like you're about to say something
oh I'll repeat my first my Gilbert
Godfried but seriously this time Matt
Matt Fast and Furious Fast and the
Furious and Mad Max okay
Mad Max Spencer so hopefully we're
getting this furiosa movie that George
Miller has been working on and it's
about a female survivor in a wasteland
and where's a better place for a strong
older maybe mentor or maybe even more
badass female character that furio's
that can link up with but Linda Hamilton
it's like kind of a wink towards
terminator we know she can do it we know
she's got the guns literally and
figuratively we know she can drive like
a badass I think that it that sounds
really cool but I feel like it kind of
dilutes the power of furiosa and kind of
repeats themes we have in the first
movie what I would like is to finally
meet Ben's mom I want a mirror I want
them to be acting guns of Linda Hamilton
before she crashes a car through 50
walls in the finale 10 second Spencer
Hughes and wisely Fitness never
mentioned his mother in the movie he's
all about his father he learned
everything in his backstory by his
father she clearly wasn't a very
important character in his life
whereas Linda Hamilton can really bring
a but a more gravitas we met a short we
met the people whom entered furiosa
there was a reason Ben's mother hasn't
been brought up because he's up so about
family then where is she I'm interested
to know I learned everything about my
father Roth you seem to be spending
there with an answer but where do you I
like them both I'll be honest but that
was where I would have gone to when
Spencer said that I was like well maybe
there's a story there then if we're not
hearing about this mother so I gotta go
guys in the couch and I like them both
there when Simon Spencer you know I kind
of really like the idea of furiosa and
Linda Hamilton together I thought that
was pretty strong and fast fierce it's
kind of the obvious if so like any
anybody could work in that series so I
think I'm like Oh Spencer
the end quickly I like them both but
here's right back because I'm taking my
preference out of it cuz I probably
would rather watch that one but I can't
you when you pulled out the fact that we
got nothing about the dad I just thought
that was more interesting you know it
was a good counter I'm gonna agree with
this Spencer and the consensus there
were four forces it questioned best
Darren Aronofsky film reckon four dream
The Wrestler Requiem and the wrestler
both really good films this will be
interesting but you only have 20 seconds
why is it better than the other film is
the only thing I'd advise in your time
go ahead it's hard to pull off a message
film that's about something and this is
about an anti-drug movie and what could
be more corny than an anti-drug movie
except he makes it real and he actually
gets people to not want to do drugs
that's what it did to me it's also the
degree of difficulty of pulling off an
ensemble piece where is all these
interconnected stories that's just hard
we've seen depressing character pieces
before like the wrestler but I don't
think it's very rare to do a movie like
crash but good whoa all right strong
start there max 20 seconds the wrestlers
better than requiem for a dream it's a
heartfelt character story about an art
that has exactly is your other movies
about it there are tons of movies about
drug addiction there are a million good
requiem for dreams rec rooms great the
wrestler is simply a better film from
start to finish it's not pretentious
like Requiem it doesn't ask as much from
the audience and at the end of the day
it's just a stronger movie as a sweeter
and stronger more heartfelt message ten
seconds
[Music]
yeah what do you mean it doesn't ask as
much of the audience you wanted to
that's why it's a great films because
reckon for dream asks a lot of you it's
a film that you have to go through that
affects you that is so good it leaves an
impression on you whereas the wrestler
yeah there there are other wrestling
movies I'm gonna give you five more
seconds
to finish your thought because I'm on
the fence and I'm gonna give you five
more to their other broke down at the
end of their career movies and there are
other wrestling movies the fact that you
combine them is admirable but 15 max to
get it all out you misunderstand what
the wrestler is about there are no other
movies about professional wrestling from
the view of it is an art form that
consumes someone completely drugs are an
outside force in the wrestler the pain
comes from within make your captures
that beautifully in the final shots of
that film like requiem are beautiful but
more well I'm coming you first
easy one those are both strong films and
strong argument really strong argues my
two favorite Aronofsky films but yeah I
feel like Max really did a great job of
summarizing what I think is the
greatness of that movie and I do think
it's interesting that nobody's ever
looked inside professional wrestling
from that personal perspective I go with
max you guys are you vote Spencer or max
because Requiem has way more to play
with like he was saying the inter 20 of
the stories and then having to deal with
such a heavy thing is drugs and it did
make an impression a lot of people from
that like you drugs and your vote
raus oh man that was my favorite fight
of the day the wrestlers my favorite
Aronofsky movie but you made some great
points and Requiem definitely does leave
an indelible impression I don't know I
don't know I really honestly I do fact
that you were able to make a joke about
the most intense and vile scene in the
movie shows the failure of what Graham
which is that it goes too far great
arguments I mean besides the fact that
they're both great films like I you you
got do it I can't do it you're not
taking a vote yeah I was asking you to
but okay then I'll go then just because
I love other words like all right so I
think we're tied so it really does come
down to me yeah I mean here's you I'm
trying to remember what cuz you said a
lot why it's a better you said it's a
better film it's a better film multiple
times and but you did give me reasons as
to why it's something we haven't seen
before
but I think Spencer also did a point of
like you haven't seen Requiem done in a
way that actually is effective like it
was because it could have easily been
corny as you said it's done sambal which
is are hard to do so just for the fact
that I just wanted to hear I've never
seen Spencer fight as hard as he did
with his points in that speed round like
he really got more foot so I just from a
fact that you got more out for me I
gotta give Spencer the points and
Spencer the win
[Applause]
one rematch someday oh man that was
intense
I have not had so much fun getting my
ass handed to the that go pull the speed
round as we wrap up and let me know if
it is there will do I do please pull of
these plugs man max landis Bravo thank
you for coming back you never disappoint
me you're one of my favorite fighters
here no doubt look like every time I go
on screen Yogi's I like something's
weird with my hair I'm wearing no it's a
little God no max seriously one of my
favorite you bring it always and you
very you you've you're maturing as here
as a fighter I thought you with your
best you've ever been it's been
wonderful to see this thank you what it
where are you when I plug her to send
people to um oh [ __ ] the joke you made
about the carly rae jepsen yes i
discovered and this isn't a joke yeah
but i discovered a pattern in the music
of carly rae jepsen that has been going
on for 17 years and is real which is one
of the weirdest I know I sound insane
when I talk about it but I can actually
prove to you that it's real and I'm not
just talking about themes and pop music
I'm talking about a specific story
whether she intends it to be happening
or not I don't know I don't know
anything about the person but the
evidence is there in the music and if
you do read it you will actually be
convinced that she read it I have no
idea I wasn't asking dirt Jen Lisa q0e
Bude last night on sci-fi channel which
is incredible show run by Nick and pasta
and dominant scene and creator of
child's play and we got it got a good
audience and it's really good dark comes
back near the end of October I wish I
had a date but the show I shall run my
heart the thing I pour myself into dirt
comes back in October and then I have a
comic coming out in a DC Comics
Christmas special and then I have a
bunch of other stuff that I'm not
allowed to talk about I know I'm excited
for a gal gadot and in deeper it's cool
it's cool
movies unless I like I don't talk about
them anymore because I used to be like
the guy who's like tweeting about
everything all the time and then like
people are you're passionate people just
don't like passion sometimes I think
because it's not what they agree with
Roth corn net Bravo great job screen
junkies news screen jockeys news every
single day thank you for letting me come
do loud noises
yeah with with my serious jet lag and
last minute really thank you for cut
stepping you or you were wonderful yeah
thank you my time to yell yeah you did
it every time I say I'm not gonna yell
you got him said the best pitch on
movies I mean that's a Windows pretty
good you guys yeah it pretty good
you guys are killers and amazing this
was really fun I really love that
Aronofsky fight he went serious right
now and those are tough meet Ron you've
ever done I noticed it a madam award it
there to Spencer Gilbert I am capable
being serious sometimes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
great job amigo thank you and Nico any
when you send send our fans
yes it's following me on Instagram Nico
is a moon man that post photography in
short film yeah support Nico thanks man
Andean Wow amazing fan art can anywhere
where we send people to find your
brilliant work facebook.com slash art of
Ian and Michelle Candice CND is a chair
Mike might can hear something sure they
got that plug and Ian is e w a bow I am
thank you my jet fun o always yeah love
it and this I love this picture and
totally framing this up and put it on
the set
um and take you out home you follow me
any signor and socials etc as always and
go see all these peoples wonderful work
and we will be here next week live once
again for another movie fights have a
great one bye Mike brought to you by
t-mobile now family plans include
Netflix at no extra charge another
reason why t-mobile is America's best
unlimited network
[Music]
you